[موسيقى]
حياكم الله جدد البنك المركزي الهنديه
رفضه هو الاعتراف بالعملات المشارفه وحدره
محافظ البنك المركزي الهندي من ان الفشل
في تنظيم سوق العملات المشفره قد يتسبب في
ازمه ماليه عالميه مقبله مطالبا باعتماد
الروبيه الرقميه لتلبيه احتياجات البنوك
الرقميه وعزاء المحافظه بتنظيم سوق
العملات المشفره الى ان هذه العملات ليس
لها قيمه اساسيه والتداول بها يعتمد على
المضاربه البحته يشار الى ان العملات
المشفره في الهند منعت في العام 2018 ثم
اعيد طرحها قبل عامين مع انعاش هذا القطاع
بفضل تطوير منصات للتداول ودعم من بعض
الشخصيات
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا عبر زوما من عمان طلال طباع
الرئيس التنفيذيه لاكوين مينا من بيروت
الدكتور جهاد الحكيم استاذ التمويل الدولي
في الجامعه الامريكيه في بيروت الحكيم
عفوا شكرا اهلا بكما
طب ليبدا اولا ااا من ااا من بيروت
الدكتور جهاد الدكتور جهاد اهلا بك يعني
هذه العملات هل توافق اما ذهب اليه محافظ
البنك المركزي الهندي من ان لا قيمه لها
لهذه العملات المشفره
شكرا للاستضافه
لا يمكنني القول او الجزم ان لا قيمه لها
بشكل عام لكن ااه هذا يختلف من عمله الى
اخرى لكن هناك الكثير من العملات المشفره
همم هي همم فقط وجدت همم من اجل ان يكون
هنالك ضرب احتيالي وراءها وليس هنالك اي
مقومات همم اقتصاديه همم تدعم هذه العملات
وليس هنالك من مشاريع وراء هذه العملات
وراينا ان حتى ما يعتبر او ما يسمى باستيب
الكوين على سبيل المثال كاترلونه وقع
ضحيتها همم الملايين المتداولين
والمستثمرين وخسر المليارات
وقد راينا ان هذا الامر انسحب ليس فقط على
العملات المشفره انما ايضا على شركات
ومنصات تداول كبيره كان يثق بها
المتداولين واا وقعوا ضحيه افلاسها
ولقد تبخرت
استثماراتهم وادخاراتهم واا لذلك يجب
التنبؤ من عمليات الاحتيال الكبيره وحتى
اكبر شركه التي نعرف انهم يتداولون عليها
كبورصه للعملات الرقبيه كباينس هي هنالك
دعاوى همم طويله المدى من اجل همم الوقوف
وراء همم اذا كانت هذه
الشركه هي تنتقل لقوانين همم مكافحه
الارهاب الامريكيه وغسل الاموال ام هي لا
تنتسب وبالتالي هنالك همم همم قارس
بالنسبه للعملات الرقميه هنالك غياب تام
للصقر وهنا وكنا نعرف انه في دعم تفضل
دعني انتقل الى الى ضيفي من عمان طلال
طباع الرئيس التنفيذي لتكوين مينا سيد
طلال يعني العملات المشفره لا قيمه لها
رغم ان ضيفي من بيروت يقول بعضها نعم
والبعض حتى يقول من انه هي متاجره بالوهم
ومضاربه بالوهم ليست اموالا حقيقيه
اول شيء انا بحترم راي الدكتور همم لانه
كان موزون وانا موافقه وفي كثير من
العملات الرقميه ما لها قيمه ولكن في كثير
من العملات الرقميه في من وراها مغزى وفي
من وراءها تكنولوجيا قويه جدا همم
اتوقع ما بيصير الاجسام على كل العملات
الرقميه هلا اذا في شركه همم نزلت على
السوق المالي وتم افلاسه ما بنحكي انه كل
الاسهم سيئه بنفس الطريقه اذا في عدد
عملات كبيره همم طلعت معموله من
والاعتتيال هذا لا يعني انه بدكم نثير يم
وغيرها من المناطق اكثر من عمله واكثر
منصه واكثر من سوق اذا بتسمح لي انت اليوم
ممكن تنزل عمله عمله رقمي تقدر تنزلها
بخمس دقائق وبتقنع ناس ثانيين يقدر
يشتروها ففعلا صار في عمليه قصب واحتيال
ولكن هذا بيصير باي تكنولوجيا جديده راح
تغير العالم ما بعرف اذا كنت على انا ما
كنت على وقت الانترنت ولكن قراءه اا كثير
من استخدامات الانترنت باول ايامها كانت
تستخدم لادوات نصب واحتيال وغيرها من
الاشياء اللي اليوم بنطلع انه والله
الانترنت كثير فقدت العالم مع انه
ببداياتها كانت تستخدم لسوبر غير نبيله
خلينا نحكي طيب يعني همم المدير البنك
المركزي او محافظ البنك المركزي الهندي
يقول بان اساسها هي مضاربات وليست مشاريع
تمام تمام هلا اذا انت رحت سالت فندق معين
شو رايكم باير بي ام بي او رحت سالت صاحب
تاكسي شو رايه باوبر اكيد راح يقولك مش
كويس اذا بتسال محافظ بنك مركزي شو رايه
بالعملات الرقميه كمان راح يكون رده فعله
عليهم وخصوصا البنك مركزي بنك المركزي
الهندي وين رايهم على العملات الرقميه
كانوا متقلب اول شيء حكوا مانع بعدين
سمحوها وحطوا ضريبه 30% لاحظوا انه ما
بيقدروا يحضروها بنفس الطريقه اللي كانوا
متخيلين وهلا رجعوا منعوها
بس لانه حكومه منعت شيء انا برايي هذا ما
لازم يغير راينا يعني مثلا ان السوار ستاد
كان ممنوع يدرسوا قبل 60 سنه هل هذا شيء
انت بتوافق فيه
اليوم طالبان يفعلون هذا الشيء ده طلال
طيب خليني اذهب الى بيروت
معي من هناك الدكتور جهاد يعني همم هل
المضاربه ما طرحها ضيفي من عمان هي واقع
من النمو مو كل ال ال العملات ولكن ايضا
البعض ان الحكومات تريد السيطره على هذا
السوق الذي قد لا تسيطر عليه
همم المشكله همم
اهم عمله رقميه التي همم اعتبرها البعض
انها اصبحت بمثابه دجله الاس وهي
البيتكوين هي تعتبر نوع من الاصول قد
انهارت في همم في ظرف اقل من سنه منذ اعلى
مستوياتها همم
نوفمبر 2021 انخفضت قيمتها في مقها بحوالي
76% وبالتالي يجب التوقف عند هذا الامر
لانه حتى الاسهم همم اسهم النمو همم
التي تعتبر عاليه المخاطر لن تنخفض سوى
حوالي 33% هذه همم اخذنا الناس
اكثر ماليه كبيره همم ايضا معرضه لانهيار
وبعضها افلس على على مر الزمن مو بس ما
لها اصول ايضا لكن لم نشهد لم نشهد همم
هذا العدد من
الدروب النصب والاحتيال في فتره همم قليله
لان ما تكلمت به ليس فقط عملات كانت هي
ضرب من الاحتيال والنصب انما منصات تداول
هنا اتكلم
اتكلم
عن افتكاس اتكلم عن منصات كبيره وبالتالي
لان الكثير من
صح التعبير من المحتالين قد استغلوا وجود
العملات المشفره من اجل القيام بجني
الكثير من الارباح واستغلال بيع الاوهام
للمتداولين لانه نعرف انه ليس هذه كان من
رقابه السداري دي رجلي تدماركت عمولات
الرقميه ولا بالتالي ليس هنالك من يعوض
على من يخسر امواله حتى لو كانت
بالمليارات طيب طلال يعني الاموال تتبخر
كما قال محافظ البنك المركزي الهندي
الدكتور الان يقول بانه عمليات النصب وبمم
يعني الاموال في مهب الريح طيب سؤال نحن
حكينا عن البنك المركزي لا جاوبني بس امي
قالت الدكتور وطرحها هذا هذا هاجس تمام
تمام اول شيء شركه نت فليكس اللي هي تعتبر
من الاسهم للجلوس نازله اكثر من 60% هذه
السنه سهم امازون ببداياته في سنه نزل
اكثر من 75% همم بس نحن عم نقارن باسهم
اليوم مش نفس الشيء خلينا نطلع على البنوك
المركزيه الليره اللبنانيه الليره التركيه
همم
هذول فعليا حتى مش انت انه نسبه قيمتهم
انت ما بتقدر تسحبهم من البنك يعني البيت
كويسين صح نزل 70% ولكن تقدر تاخذ البيتكو
انت معك بكرامتك وتروحوا على اي بلد ثاني
بالعالم اذا كان عندك ادخارات بمصر بلبنان
بغيرها مش بس تتبخرت هي صفت
ارقام فقط على شاشه وانت ما بتقدر
تستخدمها ف- اا صح الثقه بالمدى القصير
اللي بيتكم وغيرها من العملات الرقميه
اكلت ضربها هذا شيء مؤكد واكبر سبب له كان
يعني نبقى على بيتكم طلال ماهي هذه
بس نبقى على البيتكوين ما في عملات اخرى
ثانيه موثوقه غياب الرقابه من يراقب
تمام فاليوم في حكومات وبنوك مركزيه حوالي
العالم بترخص منصات العملات الرقميه بشكل
كامل زي البنوك المركزيه طيب اليوم البنك
المركزي البحريني مرخص منصات عملات رقميه
شركه كوين بيس مدرجه على السوق المالي
الامريكي على على يعني تقدر تشتري وتبيع
اسهم شركه كوين بيس فواضح يعني ما كان
سمحت لكوين بيس تدرج والناس تقدر تداول
اسومها لو النشاط تبعها مخالف من عمان
طلال طباع الرئيس التنفيذي لكوين مينا
شكرا جزيلا لك ومن بيروت الدكتور استاذ
تمويل الدولي في الجامعه الامريكيه في
بيروت ايضا للشكر
جزيلا لكم
الشكر موصول لكم انتم ايضا المزيد من
الاخبار مع الزملاء في نشراتنا المستمره
على العربيه تابعون معنا في امان الكريم